hello my name is Josh Malaya I'm a
senior marketing product manager at
Milton E biotech and thank you for
joining this webinar presentation about
the rise of neuro immunology and about
the tools and solutions that we offer to
help you navigate the research and
translational challenges during the next
revolution human health
in today's webinar we will cover the
following topics starting with the
history of Milton a biotech followed by
a brief background of neuro immunology
we will then take a look at the
different products and technologies that
together comprise the complete workflow
from Milton in biotech we start with the
importance of sample preparation
followed by the core of Mac's technology
which is magnetic cell separation next
we will discuss which factors to
consider for reliable and reproducible
cell culture and phenotypic analysis of
target cells we complete the workflow
with our new imaging platform and will
then move on to some example
publications for various neural
immunology related applications finally
we will wrap up the webinar with a quick
summary and supporting materials we will
first start with a brief introduction of
Milton e biotech Milton E biotech was
founded in 1989 by Stephan Milton E in
the basis of max cell isolation is the
column technology developed as a part of
his diploma thesis with the technology
being patented in 1990 the potential for
max technology to become a revolutionize
er in the field of gene therapy became
obvious in the Clinton Mac's cd34
reagent system for selecting
hematopoietic stem cells from donor
apheresis was developed the clinical
evolution of the company has continued
for over 20 years including setting up a
GMP manufacturing site in tetrode
germany and in 2014 the fda gave
approval for cd34 isolation using the
clinton macs together with the clinton
mac cd34 reagent what started out as the
diploma thesis has since grown into a
global company of 3,000 employees and
over 20,000 scientific publications
citing mike's technology annually more
than 2,500 patients receive cell
products manufactured with no pending
biotech technologies while we have
thousands of products and servants and
services as a company we have one
mission the word
empowering discovery and advancing
therapy define our company's mission
which is to improve scientific
understanding and medical progress by
providing solutions that advance
biomedical research and cellular
therapies as a company we are able to
achieve this mission by our ongoing
commitment of bringing newer and smarter
technologies to the scientists and
clinicians who are paving the way to
longer and healthier lives so why are we
here talking about neural immunology
let's take a look at a little bit of the
history in rationale for focusing on
this topic
neural immunology is the interaction of
the immune and nervous systems two of
the most complex biological systems
known in nature with significant
scientific and financial efforts
directed towards the development of
approaches of approaches to diagnose
treat or prevent neurological diseases
for decades the brain was thought to
have immune privilege operating
autonomously from the immune system this
has been systematically disproven by
numerous studies showing the extensive
interactions that exist between these
two biological systems neurological
disorders with immune components have
been documented for centuries thoroughly
though the etiology and treatment of
many of these neurological disorders
remains elusive the recorded history of
neurological disorders dates back over
400 years with the first recognition and
documentation of such conditions such as
multiple sclerosis and ALS additional
conditions were later identified in the
19th and early 20th centuries and these
include Parkinson's Huntington's and
Alzheimer's disease fast forward to the
21st century and there have been
numerous advancements and our
understanding of the disease
pathogenesis and many failed clinical
trials have been held to combat these
various diseases these trials include
failed vaccines for Alzheimer's disease
and attempted stem cell therapies and
targeted depletion of b-cells for
multiple sclerosis so if Maria if neural
immunology has been around for hundreds
of years why this webinar about the rise
of neuro immunology to understand this
rationale we need to consider the
current and future threats to human
health and how the relationship between
the brain and the immune system is
likely to be at the forefront of human
health in the future
when we look at how the top 10 global
cost causes of death have changed during
the 21st century we can see that
diabetes heart disease and Alzheimer's
disease and become more common a more
common cause with death but what about
the future let's take a look at what the
World Health Organization thinks the
trends are going to be focusing on the
top three causes of death being heart
disease cancer and neurological diseases
when we look at the predicted cause of
death over the next 40 years we can see
that brain diseases are anticipated to
become more and more of a health threat
especially in wealthy nations in the
u.s. cancer and heart disease are the
leading causes of death but we are
seeing a slight decline in the
prevalence with neurological and
infectious diseases making the greatest
gains
what we see and perceive to seem to be
different things when it comes to death
this graph shows what we actually die
from on the Left what we search for on
Google and what we see on TV all of
which are quite different this was
demonstrated in this graph depicting on
how under or over represented causes of
death are reported by the media
NIH funding however and obviously has
neuroscience as a priority as is evident
by the projected funding for 2020
there are a number of different
immunological example applications it's
broken down into four primary categories
the first being cancer with the most
prevalent being glioblastoma
there's also astrocytomas and adenoma
their immunological disorders such as
multiple sclerosis SLE or CNS vasculitis
degenerate diseases include Alzheimer's
disease Parkinson's disease ALS and
Huntington's disease and the other
category includes stroke and traumatic
spinal entering infection like
psychiatric conditions and genetic
conditions all of which have been found
to have immunological components
now that we've gone over the history of
neuro immunology a little bit now we're
going to focus on the workflow from
Milton a biotech this goes from sample
preparation to cell analysis so we start
with a solid tissue and we move on to
our sample preparation this is followed
by cell separation and various
downstream applications such as cell
culture cell analysis single cell
sequencing or proteomics and we're also
introducing our new imaging platform
we're first going to cover the
importance of sample preparation so this
section will cover sample preparation
one of the most critical aspects of any
workflow the quality the quality of your
starting material will define the
quality of your results
the basic principle of sample
preparation of taking a solid piece of
tissue and using both mechanical
disrupter and disruption and in thematic
digestion to dissociate the tissue into
a single cell suspension there are three
primary goals that need to be achieved
to reproducibly generate single-cell
suspensions of viable and recognized
recognisable populations
brain tissue tumors or organs you begin
with a mixture of cells embedded in the
extracellular matrices basal membranes
vasculature vasculature fat and possibly
necrotic tissue often making target
cells difficult to isolate and
characterize the first goal is to
consistently dissociate your starting
materials through a combination of
enzymatic and mechanical disruption
common methods include generating
concoctions of enzymes from various
vendors that widely varying source
activity purity and even nomenclature
and combining this homebrew with a
manual dissociation process using razors
scissors possibly mashing pushing tissue
through a mesh or bead Mills the result
is a dissociation process that is
difficult to reproduce due to the number
of product and individual individual
variables the second goal is to preserve
cell surface epitopes which are
essential for the identification and
characterization of various cell types
and subpopulations
in addition preserving cell surface
epitopes may be essential for downstream
applications and functional analyses but
how are you to know which epitopes are
susceptible to enzymatic digestion and
at which concentrations and what for
what duration not knowing which epitopes
are affected by your sample preparation
protocol can lead to misidentification
of subpopulation and disruptive
artifacts finally maintaining cell
viability and functionality is essential
for any meaningful downstream analysis
so minimizing the amount of both the
mechanical and enzymatic dissociation
along with the utilization of consistent
and defined reagents is paramount for
success
we know that these goals are important
but consistently acquiring defined
reagents in combination with human
variation can make this process very
labor-intensive info variable
fortunately we have a solution in the
gentle max with the gentle Max octo
dissociate with heaters we offer a fully
automated tissue processing instrument
to standardize the dissociation and
modernization of your starting materials
with this technology we combine
mechanical dissociation and enzymatic
digestion on the same instrument 8
samples can be processed at once in
parallel or independently and every
position is individually tempered for a
efficient enzymatic dissociation here
different applications can run on
different positions at the same time or
you can start experiments unavailable to
available positions even if others are
occupied by other lab members making it
a great instrument for diverse
laboratories
we offer a wide range of protocols and
kits for the applications of cancer and
neuroscience immunology stem-cell and
cardiovascular research it would
encourage you to visit our website to
discover the breadth of our technologies
and supporting materials for your
research
the next step in the inderal immunology
workflow is cell separation which takes
us to the next section that will
describe the fundamentals and advantages
of max technology
in this next section we're going to be
talking about cell separation using max
technology
technology is based on three principles
first magnetic labeling where an
antibody conjugated to a tiny
paramagnetic micro bead binds to a
receptor or protein on the cell surface
there are different strategies for the
step which will be covered in more
detail later in the presentation second
we have magnetic separation the process
where cells are passed through a column
that is positioned within a magnet the
cell is labeled with the microbeads are
retained in the column whereas
everything else passes through in a
gentle way the flow-through is called
the negative fraction containing the
cells without the antibody third in the
aleutian step the column is removed from
the magnet enabling the paramagnetic
allele abled cells allow meaning that
they lose their magnetic system outside
of the separator which allows them to
pass freely through the column this can
be achieved through a quick manual step
using a plunger to gently loot the cells
or via an equally gentle automated
process using a vacuum to pull the cells
out or increasing the flow speed of the
buffer in the system all three methods
are gentle for the cells and separate
the cells into a negative and positive
fraction with exceptional purity and
high viability
these key components are the max
microbead the max column and the max
magnetic separator there are several
versions of each available depending on
your starting material cell type of
interest and whether you're looking for
a manual or automated system since the
column is the core of max technology
let's take a quick look at the benefits
and why it is clearly the superior
choice when compared to column free
methods the magnetic separators and
column based and column free systems
have a comparable magnetic force the
difference between the two systems is
the column filled with little iron
spheres that pass the magnetic force
onto the next over a very small distance
amplifying the magnetic force by ten
thousandfold
the resulting benefit is that minimal
labeling of the cells with microbeads is
sufficient to retain the target cells
within the column while in the separator
the iron spheres have a cell friendly
coating allowing cells to run freely
through the column and can be washed
thoroughly to remove cell debris and
contaminants all of this contributes to
the fact that max columns allow for cell
separation with minimal effects on cells
combined these advantages make max
columns to betch the best choice for
cell separation for neural immunology
why do we need Adam ation Automation
reduces hands on time and frees you to
work on more important tasks that cannot
be automated
it minimizes variation between different
users in the lab or even good and bad
days of individual scientists and of
course minimizes costly human errors
with standard protocols and minimum
using user variation you can be sure
that the effects that you're saying are
due to your assay rather than artifacts
in short automation reduces redundant
experiments and allows you to focus your
time where it matters now I'd like to
introduce you to the Milton e biotech
automated solutions for magnetic cell
separation we'll start with the Auto
maxpro separator the easy-to-use
benchtop instrument for every laboratory
with fully automated sequential
separation of 1 to 6 samples the automax
provides easy access to automation
without high investment costs or lots of
training you can mix many different
starting materials and samples within
one run you press the Run button and the
instrument will label and separate the
cells for you the columns are reusable
so maintenance is easy and there are
preset programs for high recovery and
high purity depending on your downstream
applications next we have the multi-max
cell 24 separator plus this semi
automated instrument was designed for
those with higher throughput needs or
for those processing lots of cells
example from a Luca pack finally we have
the multi-max X launched in 2017 this is
the instrument for the demanding high
throughput cell processing lab samples
are labeled and isolated automatically
and you can go from an entire buffy coat
to target cells in 30 minutes or from a
Luca pack in 60 minutes all programs are
tailored to match your needs so we won't
leave your lab until you're satisfied
with the protocol and the results in
summary the autumn ax pro is great for
small samples and low throughput with
full automation for example when
processing DBM see a loquats
Mouse samples or patient arrives ena
graphs because the auto maximum process
whole blood blood without cycle it's
also great for patient samples or small
donor samples on the other hand the
multi-max family are the high throughput
variants for fast parallel processing
for example of small human or Mouse
samples but also for large blood
products such as leuco packs after
you've isolated yourselves many
applications require subsequent cell
culturing experiments and phenotypic
analysis the importance of using
optimizer agents and protocols cannot be
understated as reproducibility not only
by the investigator but by others
depends on this
sella culture and stimulation portfolio
comprises a specialized and versatile
range of fill culture media and reagents
for the stimulation expansion and/or
differentiation of human and mouse
primary cells
these include immune cells stem cells
neural cells and tumor cells small
molecules and reprogramming
reprogramming reagents are available for
stem-cell research and we offer
chemically defined specialty media for
the production of recombinant proteins
and eukaryotic cell lines selected
antigens recombinant cytokines and cell
culture media are produced according to
relevant GMP guidelines enabling a
seamless transition into the clinic
we offer a number of lineage-specific
media solutions that are xeno and serum
free that allow you to avoid the
disadvantages with associated with
animal derived components that can cause
significant variation in your cell
cultures these includes stem cell media
for IPS HSC or MSC s immunological media
for T cells and K cells and DCs as well
as neuro specific media for neuronal
cultures from the expansion and
differentiation media our media's are
designed and quality tested for
reliability and efficiency whether
you're performing basic or translational
research Milton E biotech develops
specialized cell culture media so that
you can get a head start in your
experiment Media alone though isn't
enough to expand your target cells of
interest with many relying on the
addition of cytokines and growth factors
for the expansion and differentiation of
yourself so let's talk about cytokines a
little bit
cytokines and growth factors are
available in three quality grades
research premium and GMP using max
premium grade cytokines you can rely on
the lot specific cytokine activity value
providing the certificate of analysis
learn how unit specific cytokine dosing
can help save you time increase cell
culture reproducibility and reproduce
reduced costs this also facilitates a
seamless transition into the clinical
research of using max GMP cytokines
we also offer a No
stimulation and differentiation reagents
for T cells and K cells B cells mo DC
differentiation and stem cell
differentiation among others a majority
of our cell culture reagents have GMP
counterparts for those of you that are
looking to transition into the clinic by
allowing us to support you from bench to
bedside so in order to successfully
achieve this transition you must have a
reproducible product reproducible
product manufacturing and defined
characterization methods one common
method is flow cytometry which uses
fluorescently labeled antibodies to
detect both surface and intracellular
proteins proper phenotype ting is
therefore dependent on the antibody and
what it recognizes
so we've all
heard the phrase reproducibility crisis
but how many of us really in fact think
that we're in the midst of a
reproducibility crisis
a survey carried out a few years ago by
Nature showed that 90% of researchers
agree that there is either a significant
or slight problem with reproducibility
and research and that this is in fact a
very real problem there reproducible
preclinical research is a global
expensive and well recognized problem
that contributes to delays and increase
costs of drug discovery excluding
scientific misconduct which is not a
major source of year reproducibility
lack of reproducibility typically
results from the cumulative errors and
flaws and one or more of the following
non discreet categories of the research
and publication process biological
reagents and reference materials study
design laboratory protocols and data
analysis and reporting although each
contributes to a systematic problem that
requires extensive changes in the
overall scientific culture taking
immediate steps to address biological
reagent issues specifically those for
cell culture and flowing out our flow
cytometry is a relatively
straightforward fix that will improve
the credibility reproducibility and
translation of preclinical research in
2011 a nature scientific report
announced that there was a tenfold
increase in the number of retractions
over the last decade while the amount of
literature had only expanded by 44%
virtually all of these came from the
scientists with biology and medicine
accounting for nearly half of those
retractions
in 2012 Glenn Begley who ran the
oncology division on Amgen decided to
try and reproduce 53 foundational papers
in oncology he was unable to reproduce
47 of them which is 89% bear another
pharmaceutical company reported that in
the same year it was unable to reproduce
65 of the papers in its sample
biomedical literature in 2015 various
articles are published in nature
highlighting the importance of active
antibody validation and also called for
a new generation of antibodies
recombinant antibodies that are defined
by their DNA sequence in 2016 Anjan
announced that in a press release that
it would publish three studies that fail
to confirm findings these negative
results will be published and epilim
thousands newly launched published
platform called the preclinical
reproducibility in robustness none of
these papers from the 2012 example are
related to this three studies that they
plan to publish one
study conservatively estimates that the
total prevalence of your reproducible
preclinical research is to exceed 50
percent with the cost of twenty eight
billion dollars a year in the United
States alone while other researchers
have estimated that in astounding 85
percent of biomedical research is wasted
as a result of correctable problems
tools and resources your reproducible
preclinical research presents a
significant challenge that increases the
constant time to translate research into
life-saving therapies despite increasing
pressure within the academic community
to address challenges of your
reproducibility little has been done to
provide researchers with the framework
necessary to standardize research this
led to the establishment of the global
biological standards Institute which is
a nonprofit organization dedicated to
enhancing the quality of biomedical
research by advocating best practices
and standards to accelerate the
translation of breakthroughs into
therapies this institute was established
by the head of a TCC as cell culture
lines fall into the group of biological
materials and are on under as much
scrutiny as antibodies there are a
number of initiatives that are going on
with the GBS I which speak to increasing
reproducibility one is reproducibility
2020 which is determining and providing
guidelines for cell culture and antibody
validation working to standardize shared
protocols and data and providing
training for P is around reproducibility
efforts more specifically the antibody
validation initiative is determining the
best practices for al4 antibody
validation across a scientific community
Milton E biotech is a member of G BSI
and the antibody validation initiative
and we have developed a new recombinant
portfolio of antibodies and response
our RIA Finity antibodies are
recombinant antibodies that provides
superior lots of lot consistency in
purity compared to mouse or rat
hybridoma derived monoclonal antibodies
they have been recombinant li engineered
to produce highly specific antibodies
that require no FC are blocking step
additionally they all have the same IgG
one isotype requiring less isotype
controls the manufacturing process of
REO Finity recombinant antibody
antibodies ensures high performance and
consistency based on the following
aspects one they are derived from a
defined DNA sequence which encodes only
one type of heavy and light chain
ensuring high antibody purity to
production is biologically and
chemically defined with standardized
culture conditions in mammalian cell
lines which results in high lot to lot
consistency and 3 we do analytical
biochemical and cell based testing of
every manufactured blot the importance
of the mutated FC region is demonstrated
in these two figures for splenocytes the
difference between using FC are blocking
or not with either real synergy or
hybridoma antibodies is not really
significant but in tumour materials
where an upregulation of the FC r
receptor has been identified our Rhianna
bodies demonstrate a very clear
advantage when dealing with neural tumor
and immune cells all mixed together in
your starting material it is essential
that you make sure that what you were
seeing is real and not an artifact of
differential SCR expression that can
muddy your result so next we're going to
move on to a single single-cell analysis
where sample clearance is a crucial step
that removes unwanted cell aggregates as
well as dead and dying cells this is
critical as dead and dying cells can
produce toxic compounds that can
influence your cell culture as well as
being susceptible to contamination and
most importantly can have a significant
impact on your downstream application
there is no better example than when
preparing samples for single cell
sequencing and proteomics
in a study designed with 10x genomics we
looked at the performance
reproducibility and heterogeneity of
tumor populations that were prepared
using our dissociation and clearance
reagents compared to those that only use
our dissociate er alone the findings
that when were that when you filter out
red blood cells and dying cells and
remove debris the readout was
considerably better for all 3 another
common use for single cell sequencing is
identify clones of T cells or B cells
via their T or B cell surface receptors
single cell receptor sequencing can be
very difficult and expensive here we
show how isolating T cells prior to
single cell sequencing can allow for
better sensitivity and detection of rare
Colonna types
the single cell TCR sequencing was
reformed to assess clonality of tumor
infiltrating leukocytes in this example
and we were looking at either bulk or
isolated t-cells the target number fill
for sequencing was 10,000 per sample and
we here list the top 50 TCR beta CDR
three clone o types and what you can see
is that the isolated T cells we were
able to pick up on a number of Kelowna
types that were not detected using bulk
cells
an additional tool the
all sequencing single-cell proteomics is
now becoming an essential tool to
identify identify effector functions of
various cell types ISO plexus is a
company that offers single-cell
proteomic solutions and they have
established protocols that rely heavily
on the magnetic cell separation of
samples using max technology in this
example they focus on various checkpoint
and combination therapies for t-cells
tills and PBMCs in the context of
various cancer models the quality of the
data that can be acquired using
single-cell proteomics and sequencing is
dependent on the quality of your
starting materials so make sure that
your time and money are spent wisely
when it comes to sample preparation and
cell separation as these costs are
dwarfed by those at the downstream
applications the last component of our
neural immunology workflow is our new
imaging platform that allows for the
visible visualization of whole tissues
in quite including entire mouse brains
the ultra microscope is a light cheap
microscope that was designed traning
large clear samples
light sheet microscopy is based on the
ninety-degree principle that is there's
a separate light path for illumination
or oriented orthogonal to the imaging
light path this provides for
illumination of a selective plane or
sheet within a sample which eliminates
out-of-focus illumination or emission
and enables 3d imaging and high-speed
camera based image acquisition there are
four important characteristics to be
mentioned about these systems it is very
user friendly and easy to operate it
allows its design allows the easiest
exchange of samples imaging from
overview to region of interest at a
higher magnification only by turning a
knob it has a unique light sheet
illumination which guarantees superior
image quality and even on larger fields
of view third the system can handle all
current clearing solutions and finally
the ultra microscope is a system for
imaging large samples data using the
ultra microscope - has been in the
spotlight recently with numerous covers
of cell nature and the Journal of
Neuroscience feeching featuring images
acquired with this technology so this
wraps up our presentation of the Milton
a biotech workflow for neural immunology
so let's take a quick look at some key
applications and recent publications
that focus on various neural
immunological diseases
as mentioned early in the presentation
there are four primary applications of
neural immunology including cancer
autoimmunity generate diseases and other
let's start with cancer
brain cancer is a relatively rare yet
very deadly disease tumors can form
anywhere in the brain a majority of
tumors form in the frontal parietal or
temporal lobes but as mentioned nearly
any region of the brain can develop
tumors as shown by this figure of the
brain cancers that are malignant 80% of
them are gliomas glioblastoma makes up a
vast majority of the deaths and brain
cancer and is the primary cause of death
in children with brain cancer
despite significant research efforts the
matura the mortality rate of
glioblastoma has been static for the
last 30 years
this graph shows that how the advanced
stages of leo blastoma have extremely
low survival rates and it prompted
researchers to look at new ways to treat
this disease
one of the new approaches is to use
immunotherapies
in this example publication focusing on
glioblastoma the researchers looked at
tumor associated macrophages and cd8
t-cells during combination checkpoint
therapies this group utilized our gentle
max Auto with heaters our brain and
tumor dissociation kits the myelin
removal micro bead kits and utilize the
multi-max 24 to isolate C D 11 B+ cells
using our CD 11 B micro beads there are
other example publications in
autoimmunity dealing with multiple
sclerosis utilizing our micro beads and
cytokines we have papers on SLE and then
settle itis utilizing our cell
separation technologies and we also have
it on viral encephalitis if you look at
some of the various degenerative
diseases you can find recent reports
dealing with Alzheimer's Parkinson's as
well as ALS and finally there are
reference papers that identify immune
components and utilize met max
technology dealing with stroke and
traumatic spinal injury various
infections including Zika and various
psychological conditions that have
immunological compound we have gone
through the entire neural immunology
workflow starting with sample
preparation to obtain a single cell
suspension from a solid tissue cleared
of debris and dying cells for subsequent
cell separation using max technology we
highlighted the importance of having
reliable reagents for reproducible cell
culture and phenotypic analysis
including the reproducibility crisis
associated with antibodies and cell
lines we talked about the importance of
having quality starting materials for
single cell sequencing and proteomics
and finally introduce you to the newest
edition of our workflow the ultra
microscope 2 for the 3d imaging of whole
tissues thank you for your time and
please stop by the booth for additional
information about the offerings from
Milton E biotech